well welcome back to peacefulness i am
very excited now i don't get excited by
too many guests but i've always wanted
to sit down with this guy because he's
one of the well he's probably the
number one astrophysicist in the world a
rock star of space if even as we've been
sitting here he's been telling me what's
on my own screen behind me because to me
it looks like just a big maze that he
knows and he is neil degrasse tyson
thank you for coming you happen to be in
the country i just happened to be in the
i'm having to lure you to my studio and
i'm so happy about it just happened to
be in the hood
before we go any further what is this
thing behind we put here okay so this is
these stars that are coming through
that's just special effects but in the
background is an actual image of the
milky way galaxy really and coming up
right now is the galactic center behind
us and the center there is there's it
lurks a supermassive black hole dining
on any stars that wander too close look
you have a gigantically large brain for
this kind of stuff right you accept that
it's the same size as everybody else's
brain i just prioritize what i care
about differently from others
well i think what you're brilliant to do
you've got this terrific book which will
come to the moment but you're
brilliantly crystallizing the really
important questions in life one of which
is how long have we got here
yeah well there are some ideas about
that because we still don't know enough
about the forces that will end at all
sorry uh we might have a hundred years
on earth
at the rate we're going
really no sorry there's earth issues
that require geopolitical solutions
self-harm okay correct and then there's
the universe the death of the sun the
collision of the milky way galaxy with
the andromeda galaxy and possibly the
big rip how would okay how would the sun
die oh sun like any star will run out of
fuel in its core and it starts changing
it starts bloating and getting so large
that it will engulf the orbit
of mercury and venus and come very close
to earth so imagine looking on the
horizon and sunrise is half the sky
okay that would be terrifying is this
even starting to happen no not yet no we
have another several billion years okay
if you're gonna prioritize with that's
right that's a dropped intro isn't it
you know people said that to start with
what you're worried about yeah let that
one go all right but there's another one
the big rip that if the expansion of the
universe accelerates
at a continued rate
and it goes unchecked
the universe will be expanding
in 22 billion years it'll expanding
faster than the fabric of space time can
keep up with it and it'll just rip
and i'm terrified by this for 22 billion
years
why are you terrified you're not going
to be here
nobody you know is going to be here
i just
it's okay to be scared of things that
we can't stop
climate change apparently are you
worried about the big rip we're going to
stop the big rip of the universe the big
rig would be it we're pretty incompetent
on so many levels i i would not hold
that whole high hope what about another
threat to civilization here i i had the
last interview with professor stephen
hawking which was a memorable experience
about his his study in cambridge
university and i asked him about the
threat of from ai artificial
intelligence this is what you say oh
sure
is artificial intelligence
going to be the end of us
and if it's not
how do we best work with it there is a
greater danger from artificial
intelligence if we allow it to become
self-designing
for then it can improve itself rapidly
and we may lose control
now i'm reading more and more about
the potential for ai to self-design is
it going to happen do you think there's
no reason to think that that won't
happen the question is
what minute will that occur
because the moment it becomes self
self-aware
and it can learn on its own what do you
learn exponentially what did he mean
professor hawking by by self-designing
well just consider how long do you go to
school to learn how to read write and do
arithmetic or lately it just looks like
people
just
read or write but no arithmetic how long
is that you're in school for years and
years and years
a computer
that is self-aware
and has access to all the knowledge of
the internet
it can build on whatever
foundation it had in the previous moment
to to accelerate that learning so it can
acquire all knowledge and all wisdom in
a matter of minutes are we empowering
this should we stop should we hit the
buffers on this there are people experts
who definitely feel that way i'm not as
apocalyptic about it i think ai is not
we're not going to build the one machine
that controls everything but right now
if you had told someone 20 years ago i
drive a car that can steer itself and
tell me where grandma's house is to
avoid traffic in real time they would
say that's ai
okay in the days of the jetsons they
imagined robots as humanoid objects
walking around doing tasks they weren't
thinking that the car was the robot that
the telescope was the robot that your
coffee machine is the robot they weren't
thinking that they had a robot operate
the coffee machine right the robot drove
your car so we if we infuse ai in all
the areas of our lives that serve our
needs then i don't see ai becoming
centralized in a way that then takes
over some people think that elon musk is
ai
you know either you knew him when he's
only worth a hundred billion yeah yeah
yeah i knew him when
uh he had a great line he says you know
how to make a small fortune in space
start with a big fortune that was a good
line but now he made a big fortune he's
doing lots of very interesting things in
space but one of the issues up there is
the space is getting quite cluttered
with stuff including elons i mean what's
the answer to this yeah it's not clear
and just today one of the reasons why
i'm in london is to attend a space
sustainability summit look at those two
words together space sustainability
uh we see these
trails of satellites going across the
sky they call them constellations of
satellites and that pisses me off
because a constellation of stars that
don't move across your sky they took our
word and caught naming their their their
satellites after this so so there's
thousands of satellites in the sky
creating these streaks how dangerous is
that
well
first it's ugly to those who want to
just bask in the majesty of the night
sky plus it makes
further space commerce hard because
space gets crowded then and some some
satellites have been
actively destroyed china did it first we
did it second russia did it third and
okay i didn't destroy your satellite i
destroyed one of my own but you saw it
okay
have you been to space i no no would you
like to i okay so you know the folks
like uh like um jeff bezos yeah all
these guys so william shatner william
shatner so if this is school room globe
you know how high up
they went
the thickness of two dimes they're
nothing really
and i'm an astrophysicist you're gonna
say that's bad i'm not where do you want
to go go to moon mars beyond giving a
destination that's not boldly going
where hundreds have gone before this
matter professor hawking told me if he
knew he had his last day on earth it was
all about to end ai or otherwise he said
he would he would want to be with his
family playing wagner and drinking
champagne
what would you do wow okay literally i
said to you right now all right you're
right the world is about to end and it's
happening in six hours what are you
gonna do i would say
what can i do
with my intellect and those of others to
prevent the world from ending in six
hours but assuming you couldn't do
anything no no i don't i don't assume
that no excuse me okay you have these
photos of people escaping cities that
are about to be leveled by a hurricane
what are you gonna do no one is saying
why don't we tap the cyclonic energy of
the hurricane use that energy to drive
the the power needs of the city and then
the hurricane goes away you know who
thinks that way stem professionals
science technology engineering and math
professor hawking he had this obsession
about working out what the black hole
was right what is your obsession what's
your weird thing you would love to crack
that's never been solved i i want to
know our equations tell us that if you
go into a black hole the time works out
so that the future history of the
universe you just came from plays out to
infinity and another space time opens up
in front of you so i want a mapping of
all the new space times that the black
holes are providing so you're all
basically obsessed with the same thing
black gold well who wouldn't be i find
them a little bit black where's
black holes the way kids are obsessed
with t-rex every kid knows a t-rex right
yeah i think it's because it's a threat
that it can eat you that that that has
earned its respect neil it's a this book
welcome universe absolutely
fantastically fascinating thank you you
you are remarkably fascinating this is
like the original textbook that spawned
a series of books this latest one is the
the universe in 3d right there are
glasses that are part of it and the
objects in the universe pop
and they're they they transform from
just a picture of a planet to
a world as a planet we even show the
constellations and you realize
constellation is spread in three
dimensions it's not just i can talk to
you sadly we run out of time what a play
it is what a pleasure please come back
again next time you're here we'd love to
have you back great great to finally
talk to you probably
you